merci d'être avec Vion pour cette
première demi-heure c'est natrice de la
Vendée je le disais vous préciser la
délégation au droit des femmes au Sénat
et vous avez remis un rapport sur les
violences du pornographiques on va
évidemment longuement parler mais
d'abord un mot puisque vous avez
additionné hier Isabelle Rome qui est la
ministre en charge de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes avec notamment
des questions autour du budget de ce de
son ministère est-ce qu'elle vous a
éclairé sur le budget alloué aux
violences faites aux femmes est-ce que
vous y voyez plus clair après cette
audition alors on sait que ça augmente
de 14%, on sait qu'il y a 1000 places
supplémentaires d'hébergement après
comme vous le voyez le programme 137
c'est une grosse patate et c'est
toujours très compliqué parce que ça se
ventile et on sait pas trop comment ça
se ventile à ce stade donc oui il y a
une augmentation oui le budget pour la
ligne 137 n'a jamais été aussi
importante la seule chose c'est qu'on
voit bien qu'on arrive toujours pas à
enrayer les violences intrafamiliales et
les violences femme donc il va peut-être
falloir un jour qu'on se dise est-ce que
c'est une question de budget est-ce que
il y a d'autres choses à faire aussi
peut-être et le rapport d'en faire du
décor et peut-être aussi bien sûr on va
en parler mais d'abord une autre
question sur cette édition d'Isabelle
Rome puisque il y avait aussi des
inquiétudes sur la baisse du budget à
l'eau au 39 19 c'est le numéro d'appel
pour les femmes victimes de maltraitance
est-ce que là-dessus elle vous a rassuré
alors elle nous a rassuré il y a le 39
19 désormais était accessible 7 sur 7 20
h 24 donc c'est une bonne chose les
appels sont en augmentation ça veut dire
que comme pour les associations le 39 19
a besoin de moyens supplémentaires et ça
bien entendu il faut y répondre on en
parle beaucoup du mytho aujourd'hui il y
a un avant un après il y a de beaucoup
plus de sollicitations des associations
beaucoup plus de sollicitations du 39 19
donc ça nécessite des compétences de la
formation des moyens humains des moyens
d'hébergement de ces associations et là
il faut y répondre et pas seulement avec
des appels à projet ça a été l'un des
points qui a été soulevé par plusieurs
sénateurs et sénatrices au cours de
cette audition stop aussi aux appels à
projets dans les territoires ce sont les
associations qui mènent des projets et
qui n'ont pas forcément les ressources
humaines les ressources en interne pour
répondre à des grands appels à projets
et donc candidater et être tenu donc oui
il faut des moyens pour ces associations
mais des moyens considérables sans des
procédures d'accès aux moyens trop
compliqué et pour l'instant ça reste
quand même assez compliqué allez on va
parler de ce rapport un rapport choc que
vous avez remis sur les violences dans
le milieu de la pornographie et notre
journaliste américain a réalisé un
documentaire sur ce sujet il vient nous
rejoindre pour en parler
[Musique]
vous avez donc réalisé un reportage
suite au rapport remis par le Sénat sur
les violences en milieu de la
pornographie d'abord quel est le point
de
départementage que nous a livré une
femme que nous appellerons Pauline un
jour pauline est approché par une autre
femme sur les réseaux sociaux et solide
amitié avec elle à ce moment la police
ne va pas très bien les vulnérables elle
est en manque d'argent et ce qu'elle
ignore c'est que derrière le profil
Facebook de la bonne copine qui gagne sa
confiance et bien se cache en réalité un
homme un rabatteur qui va la manipuler
et l'orienter vers un tournage porno
lors duquel Pauline dit subir un viol on
écoute un extrait de son récit
on est en pleine campagne dans une
maison quasi vide donc avec eux des
hommes je crois qu'ils étaient quatre
jours de calvaire et 5 scènes ultra
violentes avec plusieurs hommes en
Normandie puis en région parisienne il y
a toujours en fait cette vulnérabilité
financière qui fait que je me dis je ne
peux pas repartir sans cet argent ils
m'ont tous vu pleurer il y a personne
qui s'est dit non moi je peux pas la
toucher parce qu'elle pleure ils ont
tous continué ils ont tous dit qu'ils
allaient m'achever comme si en fait
j'étais c'est comme si c'était une
chasse à courre et que j'étais un je
sais pas une biche qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait achever en fait il fallait
m'achever
alors Pauline a depuis été entendue par
la justice dans une enquête qui concerne
des dizaines d'autres victimes présumées
et qui a provoqué plusieurs mises en
examen et c'est en partie suite à cette
affaire que la délégation au droit des
femmes du Sénat que vous présidez madame
billon a décidé de s'emparer de ce sujet
et d'enquêter sur les pratiques parfois
peu recommandables de l'industrie
pornographique avec au centre la
question du consentement des femmes qui
prêtent leur corps à cette industrie des
femmes qui sont souvent en situation de
fragilité comme on vient de voir dans le
cas de Pauline nous avons rencontré
notamment le journaliste Robin d'Angelo
il est l'auteur d'un livre enquête sur
le porno et ce qui nous raconte permet
de comprendre pourquoi la notion de
consentement peut être problématique sur
un tournage porno et pourquoi ceux qui
seraient considéré comme un viol
n'importe où ailleurs et bien là ça
passe parce qu'on est sur le tournage
d'un film porno on écoute Robin Angelo
on est sur un tournage ou de l'ambiance
et super bonne le réalisateur se
comporte plutôt bien avec l'actrice mais
arrive un moment où l'actrice finalement
n'a plus envie de faire de la sodomie au
moment au moment lié confronté donc bah
voilà elle va dire NON NON à l'acteur
j'ai pas envie je me sens pas dans je me
sens pas de le faire je me sens pas le
faire et là finalement le producteur est
un peu piégé puisque enfin lui il
s'estime piégé puisqu'il dit j'ai vendu
au diffuseur qu'il y aurait de la
sodomie dans mon film donc bah comment
faire comment on fait ma cocotte il lui
dit il a dit non non mais je veux pas le
faire et là il insiste il insiste il
insiste jusqu'à ce qu'elle sait et au
final elle va dire bon bah ok je le fais
parce que elle s'estime tenue par ce
contrat et finalement lors de cette
négociation bah c'est normal tout le
monde tout le monde trouve ça normal que
on fasse céder une actrice qui ne
veuille pas parce que bah ça fait partie
du business c'est un achat c'est un
travail comme un autre
témoignage qui paraît aberrant ça veut
dire que le consentement n'existe pas ou
très peu dans le milieu du porno comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que les profils des actrices
majoritairement évidemment en généralise
pas ce sont des femmes vulnérables et
donc une exploitation donc derrière ce
qu'on a démontré dans ce rapport porno
l'enfer du décor c'est que il y a
finalement une grosse porosité une
grande porosité entre la pornographie le
proxénétisme et la prostitution et ce
qui est expliqué dans ce témoignage
c'est que bien souvent ces femmes
vulnérables elles ont besoin de cet
argent et nous on a auditionné les les
victimes de l'affaire French boukake
huis clos et donc elles sont piégées il
y a un premier viol de soumission et
après on obtient ce qu'on souhaite
d'elle puisqu'elles sont isolées bien
souvent et donc elles ont besoin de cet
argent et elles font parce que la notion
de consentement elle n'existe pas la
notion de consentement elle devrait être
réversible à tout moment ce n'est plus
possible vous êtes vous êtes dans une
pièce dans un endroit isolé avec des
hommes une seule femme et donc il y a à
la fois ce viol de soumission et parfois
aussi on l'a constaté des soumissions
chimiques vous avez aussi montré le
témoignage de Robin d'Angelo que nous
avons auditionné avec les trois
rapporteurs ce témoignage son témoignage
son livre et et effrayant ce sont des
actes de barbarie de torture auquel
assiste ces femmes et ce qu'il faut que
tout le monde comprenne tous les gens
qui visionnent ces vidéos 19 millions de
vues uniques par mois rien n'est simulé
elle le dit elle le dit dans son
témoignage les pleurs le sang
les actes de torture les étranglements
tout est vrai tout est vrai donc comment
aujourd'hui on peut laisser ses vidéos
circuler ces millions de vidéos
circulaires sans se poser la question
c'est ces actes se passeraient dans
l'espace public et non pas derrière un
écran ou un smartphone il serait
rapidement condamné donc on ne peut pas
continuer à laisser cette industrie se
développer parce que c'est son c'est une
industrie extrêmement lucrative mais ça
veut dire si on vous écoute qu'il y a
aussi une responsabilité morale de la
part des gens qui regardent ces vidéos
de la part des citoyens alors moi je
suis on n'est pas rentré dans la
moralité parce que c'est on constate
c'est vidéo en freine ce qu'on a
constaté on a fait un constat la
pornographie il y a 20 ans elle n'a plus
rien à voir avec la pornographie
d'aujourd'hui et c'est pas parce que
elle est incontrôlée qu'elle est à
l'international qu'il faut continuer à
laisser ces images circuler donc il faut
qu'on trouve le moyen collectivement
déjà de se rendre compte des violences
qui sont perpétrées avec et les
conséquences que ça aussi sur les
personnes qui visionnent et puis qu'on
se enfin qu'on s'attaque à ce problème
au niveau de la société au niveau des
politiques publiques parce que pour
l'instant on peut le dire clairement
c'est un angle mort il y a aussi ce
problème de respect de la loi mais je
pense qu'on va y revenir on va en parler
parce que vous venez de le dire il y a
une frontière finalement qui est assez
mince entre pornographie et prostitution
vous en parlez dans votre rapport vous
en parlez dans vos portages Fabien
effectivement puisque au fil de vos
travaux vous avez entendu aussi les les
revendications abolitionnistes et
revendications abolitionniste à l'encon
du porno qui sont les revendications des
collectifs féministes notamment qui sont
partis civils aussi dans les dans les
affaires en cours et comme vous l'avez
évoqué on parle d'acte sexuellement
simulé monnayés dans le but de générer
du profit donc des voix s'élèvent pour
faire entrer la pornographie dans le
champ du proxénétisme argument juridique
à l'appui et c'est notamment le cas de
l'avocate Lorraine question elle défend
plusieurs parties civiles dans les
différents dossiers en cours on l'écoute
s'il y a eu par exemple un échange
monétaire pour obtenir ces pénétrations
sexuelles et que on en tire profit ou
qui a eu un recrutement on est dans le
champ du proxénétisme si en plus il y a
eu un déplacement de femmes c'est à dire
qu'on a fait venir des femmes d'un
endroit du territoire à un autre à des
fins d'exploitation sexuelle on est sur
la traite des êtres humains tout ça
évidemment est dans le dossier
donc à partir de cette lecture très
pragmatique d'un Lorraine question
entend tout simplement faire le procès
de toute une industrie au delà des
affaires en cours face à ces accusations
qui sont lourdes l'industrie en question
se défend en affirmant que ce sont les
dérives de certains de pardon les
dérives de certains qui font du tort à
toute une profession les poids lourds du
secteur que vous avez auditionné à
savoir le groupe Dorsel et la société
Arès qui est détentrice du site et de la
marque Jacquie et Michel s'abrite
derrière leur statut de diffuseur en
clair il n'était pas au courant des
actes répréhensibles de certains
producteurs avec lesquels ils
travaillaient pourtant alors ça c'est
une position qu'ils ont eu quand même du
mal à défendre lors de leur audition au
Sénat l'industrie promet en tout cas
d'instaurer des chartes déontologiques
on va écouter enfin une ancienne actrice
porno elle est devenue réalisatrice elle
s'appelle Émilie Delaunay et elle a
rédigé co-rédigé la charte déontologique
Dorsel et elle nous parle du tiers de
confiance que prévoit cette charte
c'est-à-dire une personne qui est censée
s'assurer sur les tournages que tout se
passe bien on écoute Emilie Delaunay
le tiers de confiance aussi appelé
coordinateur ou coordinatrice d'intimité
selon les tournages c'est quelqu'un qui
ne travaille pas
forcément pour la production c'est à
dire sur le tournage je n'ai pas censé
avoir un autre rôle ça peut pas être bah
tiens la maquilleuse va être le tiers de
confiance de toute façon elle est là
tout le temps les actrices l'aiment bien
ça c'est pas possible donc c'est
quelqu'un en plus elle s'assure aussi
que y ait une poubelle des préservatifs
du lubrifiant l'accès à une douche des
serviettes propres des repas chauds un
logement décent
madame billon quand l'industrie vous
parle de charte déontologique qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire est-ce que vous
croyez un porno éthique et un porno
entre guillemets code du travail alors
nous ça a pas été notre réponse du tout
parce que globalement à l'industrie de
la pornographie c'est orienté vers des
chartes de déontologie des coordinateurs
d'intimité c'est très joli tout ça mais
ça concerne très très peu de tournage en
réalité ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que l'industrie porno de la pornographie
c'est à l'international les tournages la
majorité des tournages ils sont fait en
Amérique du Nord dans les pays de l'Est
là où il y a aucune règle alors oui il
peut y avoir un porno éthique mais le
porno éthique c'est rien c'est
anecdotique en réalité ça n'intéresse
que très peu de personnes donc les
chartes de déontologie les coordinateurs
d'intimité ça va être pour 10 à 15 films
quand vous avez des millions de vidéos
qui circulent donc oui on nous l'autre
jour sur votre plateau j'étais avec un
acteur un acteur alors il syndiqué il
représentait l'industrie de la
pornographie il avait tourné 15 vidéos
enfin ça représente quoi par rapport au
millions de vidéos et d'actes de
barbarie parce que l'avocate leur
question que nous avons auditionné je
peux vous assurer que les auditions avec
à huit clos avec les victimes de cette
affaire French bouké c'était le
coordinateur d'intimité c'est en France
le la charte de déontologie mais tout le
monde ne peut-être l'avait signé il y
avait probablement un contrat mais en
réalité une voix sur le tournage il y a
plus de règles il y a plus de règles ce
qui c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre en
réalité ces femmes elles sont piégées et
se sont majoritairement des femmes qui
sont piégées dans cette industrie et que
le porno éthique nous on a choisi ni la
voir réglementariste ni la voie
abolitionniste parce que la voie
réglementariste ça concernerait
en réalité rien
on dit pas que ça n'existe pas
est-ce que il y a eu un tournant aussi
dans le milieu du porno avec les réseaux
sociaux avec l'avènement des réseaux
sociaux un multiplication des réseaux
sociaux est-ce que ça fait finalement du
porno une industrie de masse et ça a
considérablement dégradé les conditions
de travail des actrices alors vous avez
entièrement raison nous on a étudié la
progression et la diffusion aujourd'hui
c'est massification de la diffusion de
la production de la consommation
pourquoi c'est depuis les années
2006-2008 l'arrivée des chaînes tubes
qui brassent des millions de de vidéos
et c'est les smartphones en réalité les
smartphones et les réseaux sociaux une
consultation sur cinq sur un smartphone
concerne des images à caractère sexuel
une sur 8 sur un ordinateur
donc c'est évidemment le moyen de
diffusion et lorsqu'on parle des réseaux
sociaux évidemment les réseaux sociaux
en réalité on parle même de circuits
courts pour only fan par exemple pour
les proxénètes parce parce que pourquoi
Oni fan qui était au départ utilisé pour
avoir on prenait un abonnement on avait
une relation privilégiée avec son acteur
préféré sa star de rock préféré
aujourd'hui on y Fab c'est
essentiellement des personnes lambda qui
mettent et des très jeunes qui mettent
des photos de des photos à caractère
sexuel et qui gagnent de l'argent comme
cela only fan avait en 2021 imaginé
retirer ses contenus à caractère sexuel
ils se sont rétractés parce qu'en
réalité désormais sur only fan les
contenus à caractère sexuel c'est la
majorité de des contenus donc ils
peuvent plus s'en priver donc on le voit
c'est vraiment très très compliqué oui
les réseaux sociaux oui les chaînes
tubes sont les acteurs de cette
industrie de la pornographie et c'est
c'est à l'échelle internationale c'est
pour ça que les chartes de anthologie on
peut les appliquer on peut dire bah
tiens on va installer des chartes de
déontologie leur travail le retour du
consentement mais les vidéos quand elles
sont tournées à Bucarest ou en Amérique
du Nord ça servira pas à grand chose en
réalité une des grosses une grosse
partie de votre apport c'est consacrée
évidemment à la protection des mineurs
comment on protège les mineurs de cette
exposition porno puisque aujourd'hui
l'accès est finalement facile pour les
mineurs quand on voit dans votre rapport
que 90% des scènes comportent des
violences est-ce que il y a un risque
parce que c'est le cas aujourd'hui que
les jeunes et à l'esprit finalement que
les violences dans le sexe et la norme
alors
ce qu'il faut dire pour les mineurs
c'est quand même que le Sénat il y a
deux ans avec un amendement de Marie
Mercier avait
avancé sur le contrôle de ces images
pour empêcher des adolescents des
mineurs de voir ces images aujourd'hui
c'est pas la réalité vous cliquez j'ai
18 ans vous accédez directement et même
d'avoir avant d'avoir cliqué la majorité
des mineurs peuvent être exposés de
manière involontaire donc oui ça
entièrement 12 ans deux tiers des moins
de ça a des conséquences graves sur leur
construction sur les adultes qui sont
qu'ils vont devenir avec un déficit
d'empathie un déficit d'empathie dans
les relations humaines sexuelles et bien
entendu ça provoque et ça a été démontré
au cours de nos auditions des troubles
de l'alimentation du comportement de la
tension des conduitaristes et une
normalisation de de pratiques sexuelles
qui n'ont rien de normal qui ont en
réalité qui sont totalement banalisés
nous avons eu témoignage dans un collège
dans lequel nous nous sommes rendus avec
les trois rapporteurs Alexandra borque
Fontain Laurence Cohen et Laurence
Rossignol
d'une infirmière qui nous expliquait que
un couple d'adolescents était amoureux
ils ont décidé d'avoir des rapports
sexuels le seul logiciel le seul disque
dur du garçon le seul référentiel
c'était la pornographie donc je
t'étrangle je te tire les cheveux et je
te double pénètre je suis désolé le
matin de vous parler de cette façon là
mais vous imaginez
l'état de la jeune fille et un
psychothérapeute nous a dit en réalité
la vision de ces images pour des enfants
c'est un viol psychique donc sur leur
construction et on était en plateau
l'autre fois il disait
des enfants sont terrorisés à la vue de
ces images parce qu'ils se disent mes
parents font ça
c'est terrible mais est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut aussi revoir l'éducation
l'éducation sexuelle ça manque
aujourd'hui dans l'éducation nationale
or c'est dans la loi dans la loi il y a
des séances obligatoires à la vie
sexuelle à la sexualité à la vie
affective elles sont pas peu ou mal
dispensées en gros hier la ministre nous
a dit que c'était de l'ordre de 15% je
crois dans les établissements scolaires
donc ça veut dire rien et en plus il y a
un vrai sujet c'est
quel contenu parce que si vous êtes en
train de parler d'anatomie à des
adolescents alors qu'ils ont visionné
des images de pornographie depuis leur 9
ans vous comprenez qu'on est
complètement hors sujet donc il faut
bien entendu que la loi soit appliquée
pour cela et comme pour le l'accès des
mineurs à des images voilà il faut tout
faire pour empêcher cela il faut qu'elle
soit appliquée mais qu'on adapte aussi
les contenus donc
il faut avoir un référentiel et qu'on se
dise on le fera pas si on a du temps on
le fait parce que si on arrive pas à
avancer sur les violences
intrafamiliales c'est peut-être qu'on a
un sujet de Fond de société par rapport
aux relations entre les sexes aux
relations sexuelles basiques sur la
suite de votre apport on le disait 23
propositions vous rencontrez la ministre
Isabelle Rome le 18 octobre prochain
qu'attendez-vous maintenant du
gouvernement alors bien entendu on a 23
propositions sur la table on va aller
les présenter bien entendu à la ministre
en charge de de ce sujet on va les
présenter également officiellement à
notre président Gérard Larcher l'idée
bien entendu c'est de porter ses
propositions au plus haut niveau et
d'agir vite il y a des propositions dont
le gouvernement doit s'emparer mais
s'emparer rapidement il y a
l'application de la loi par exemple sur
le contrôle de l'accès des mineurs à ces
images les cours d'éducation à la
sexualité c'est maintenant tout de suite
c'est dans la loi donc il y a d'autres
choses qui sont plus compliquées à
mettre en œuvre notamment l'écran noir
notamment le contrôle de l'identité ça
il va falloir y travailler ensemble
probablement ça veut dire qu'il y a des
solutions on n'est pas impuissant face à
ces violences dans le milieu du porno ah
non on n'est pas impuissant et lorsqu'on
a décidé de travailler en octobre à
l'automne dernier sur ce sujet les deux
affaires l'affaire révéler dans le monde
French bouké en décembre vont nous aider
je crois à prendre conscience aussi
alors vous nous aider en ayant cette
pensée à toutes les victimes mais ça va
nous aider à avancer sur ce sujet mais
toute la société doit s'en emparer et
moi je salue le travail du Sénat parce
que
il y aura un avant et un après ce
rapport parce que si vous avez des s'il
y a des gens qui lisent ce rapport ils
vont rapidement se rendre compte qu'il y
a urgence il y a une urgence vitale on
peut pas continuer d'éduquer des
générations entières au porno ça se joue
aussi au niveau européen la bataille ça
se joue aussi au niveau européen parce
que on l'a vu dans nos travaux lorsque
les États-Unis par exemple durcissent la
réglementation pour les tournages
puisque c'était essentiellement Los
Angeles Las Vegas le nord de la Floride
et bien les tournages se déportent dans
les pays de l'Est donc oui il y a un
travail à mener aussi à l'international
et bien entendu au niveau de l'Europe
merci Fabien merci merci
et évidemment je rappelle que vous avez
réalisé ce documentaire suite au rapport
du Sénat sur les violences dans le porno
merci beaucoup Fabien on va terminer en
allant voir l'actualité du côté de la
Vendée à côté de chez vous on retrouve
Guillaume Roblet à La Roche-sur-Yon
bonjour Guillaume merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur départemental de
Ouest-France Vendée et dans Ouest-France
le récit d'une nouvelle agression d'un
élu le maire de Saint-Urbain une commune
de Vendée qui a été agressée dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
tout à fait c'est vrai que la Vendée
n'est pas le département le plus
dangereux de France il fait bon vivre et
tout on est heureux d'être en Vendée
madame la sénatrice pourrait en
témoigner mais tout n'est pas parfait
pour autant et on a été contacté par le
maire de une petite commune à côté de
Challans dans le nord-ouest de la Vendée
Didier buton il s'appelle c'était jeudi
dernier il y a une semaine il circule en
voiture dans sa commune quand un jeune
un jeune mineur en scooter a fait le
tour de sa voiture lui donner des coups
de pieds dans son rétroviseur et
certaines d'intimidation qui se sont
poursuivies de longues minutes et ce qui
nous explique c'est que ça fait deux ans
que c'est compliqué avec cette personne
qui aujourd'hui 16 ans et la réponse
pénale est compliquée sur la délinquance
des mineurs parce qu'il est mis dans des
centres et puis il s'enfuit donc c'est
le maire se sent face à une impasse ils
se sont en insécurité aussi il y a deux
choses il y a la délinquance des mineurs
mais ce que je veux surtout le point que
je vais aborder avec madame la sénatrice
c'est la sécurité des élus on est dans
un climat social tendu on l'a vu avec
les manifestations antipasses il y a
quelques mois les gilets jaunes avant il
y a une tension sociale comment elle
perçoit ça de sa fenêtre de sénatrice
merci Guillaume d'être avec nous
Monsieur le Directeur ce matin
Ouest-France et de bon matin avec nous à
Paris c'est vrai que je disais en aparté
la violence elle augmente et ça on le
ressent moi je le ressens aussi lorsque
j'ai on a rendu ces travaux sur la
pornographie beaucoup de gens m'ont
interrogé aussi par rapport au risque
parce qu'il y a eu des menaces sur des
actrices notamment je pense qu'il faut
une réponse pénale véritablement rapide
dur parce que on peut pas accepter
aujourd'hui ces actes envers les élus il
y a déjà un engagement être élu c'est un
engagement au quotidien qui nécessite
finalement beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'énergie et on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de du non-réponse pénale donc
là juste elle doit faire son boulot les
élus ils doivent être protégés et on
doit enfin réconcilier les Français avec
leurs élus enfin moi j'ai moi-même été
victime il y a de nombreuses années
lorsque j'avais un poste d'adjointe à
l'urbanisme de nombreux tags et de et
c'est une véritable agression moi le
Maire Monsieur le maire Didier button
j'imagine dans quel état il doit être
dans quel état il doit être parce que
véritablement c'est c'est une lorsqu'on
est agressé de cette matière là c'est
injuste souvent il y a pas les sanctions
derrière et quand il y a pas les
sanctions c'est compliqué à vivre et à
supporter donc merci de mettre en avant
ce sujet parce que c'est pas la première
fois qu'il y a des agressions d'élus
comme dans d'autres départements il faut
qu'on arrive à enfin contenir cette
cette
ces conflits cette haine cette
sous-jacente et que il y a une relation
normale qui s'instaure entre les élus et
la population parce que le maire en
réalité c'est la bonne a tout faire
comme dirait notre président Gérard
Larcher et donc un moment il faut aussi
respecter le travail qui est mené par
ses élus au sujet à lire dans
Ouest-France Guillaume vous allez nous
en parler ce sont la multiplication des
résidences secondaires et l'impact
évidemment sur les prix pour
l'immobilier en Vendée
c'est un vrai sujet en Vendée mais pas
que mais sur l'exemple sur le cas
vendéen il y a 95.000 biens concernés ça
représente deux logements sur 10 deux
maisons sur deux logements sur 10 sont
des résidences secondaires la situation
est plutôt inégale dans le département
c'est le littoral ou c'est en tension 82
% des résidences secondaires en Vendée
sont sur le littoral ça représente 77
624 résidents il y en a 22
000 rien que sur le pays de
Saint-Gilles-Croix-de-Vie 14000 aux
Sables-d'Olonne ça représente 30% du
parc où vous habitez madame la sénatrice
au sable d'Olonne
est-ce que il y a trop de résidences
secondaires en Vendée madame la
sénatrice alors la question du logement
et vous l'avez dit dans votre propos
elle est elle est générale en réalité
elle est générale mais la Vendée bien
entendu est concernée la tension existe
dans des tout un tas de villes on prend
de Nantes on prend Angers je prends
toutes les villes globalement il y a une
tension moi ce que je voudrais dire si
on en est là aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
eu un déficit d'anticipation aussi un
déficit d'anticipation c'est-à-dire des
politiques de logement qui soit menés à
échelle plus plus moi j'ai été adjointe
à l'urbanisme dans une commune le
Château d'Olonne à l'époque il n'était
pas fusionné avec Les Sables-d'Olonne
nous avions une politique avec le maire
Jean-Yves Burnot extrêmement proactive
c'est à dire l'achat de terrain ensuite
la construction de programme où vous
aviez tout un tas de formes d'habitée
pour permettre à des gens qui
travaillent
d'habiter sur leur lieu de travail
c'était du logement social mais pas que
de la maison en accession des terrains
libres de construction et donc moi je
crois véritablement que oui il y a
beaucoup de logements secondaires on
peut pas tirer à vue non plus sur les
logements les résidences secondaires
après il faut ajuster libre le sejuste
équilibre il n'existe pas là où j'habite
et dans les îles dans les villes pardon
et dans d'ailleurs aussi en Vendée dans
les dans les villes comme
Saint-Gilles-Croix-de-Vie il faut
injuster c'est-à-dire que probablement
que la fiscalité n'est pas adaptée
aujourd'hui pour favoriser la
construction et la
proposition de logements à l'année il y
a des résidences vacantes également il
faut véritablement avancer sur ces
sujets là la ville des Sables comme
d'autres villes des de Vendée ma vais
sollicité pour qu'on puisse enfin être
zone tendue ce qui permettrait
d'appliquer des dispositifs de taxation
mais il y a pas que la taxation comme
solution bien entendu et donc qui
permettrait d'avoir des solutions pour
construire du logement et réguler cette
offre de logement moyen un sujet qui me
tient à cœur aussi c'est les Airbnb les
Airbnb aujourd'hui c'est à dire que de
nombreuses personnes propriétaires de
nombreux propriétaires s'orientent
plutôt vers le Airbnb plutôt que la
location à l'année pour une question de
rentabilité mais pas que en réalité
parce qu'il était lorsque vous avez des
locations qui se passent mal c'est
compliqué de se séparer du locataire et
de le faire sortir donc il y a un
certain nombre de choses à mettre en
place il faut y travailler moi je
souhaite que les villes comme Les
Sables-d'Olonne rentrent dans les zones
tendues j'ai travaillé avec le maire
Yannick Moreau nous allons tenter
d'avancer sur ce sujet le gouvernement a
déjà été rencontré j'espère nous
sortront merci Anne aiguillon merci
beaucoup
qui est à La Roche-sur-Yon 15 mesures
phares pour cet hiver et après c'est à
la Une de Ouest-France avec évidemment
le plan de sobriété présenté hier par
Elisabeth borde merci Guillaume merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre
[Musique]